hey guys my name is Jess it is the 9th
of June today and I still have to make
up for having semen in the thumbnail for
episode yesterday but not in the video
so let's hope I have some good news for
you Activision has announced that the
call Judy XP event will be returning
after five years of being operator the
event will take place from September 2
24 in Inglewood California and will let
people play called do the infinite
warfare modern warfare remastered and
black ops 3 infinite warfare multiplayer
and zombies modes will both be playable
at the event in addition to modern
warfare ii mustards multiplayer and
black ops 3 score steel CPAC if you get
sick of the games you can also have a go
at nuketown paintball zombies laser tag
and an exclusive PlayStation VR
experience the events will also feature
the Call of Duty World League
Championship where 32 teams can be free
to million-dollar prize pool if you came
to go you can check out the ticket
prices and packages in our story on site
if there's Ubisoft has no patience for
cheaters as they've said that those who
were found cheating in the division will
be banned permanently on their first
offense cheating has been problematic in
the division particularly within the
dark zone where hacks can give cheetahs
a series unfair advantage since you can
easily lose lukes to other players
killing you off Ubisoft said in a blog
post that 3,800 accounts were
permanently banned for cheating last
month but most only suffered 14-day
suspensions which didn't prove to be
adequately dissuasive they explained
judging from your feedback and based on
what we've witnessed when cheetahs came
back to the game we've now decided to
push our policy one step further we will
now start applying permanent ban on
first offense at when players are caught
using Cheat engines and we will
communicate clearly when you ban waves
are taking place this news comes shortly
after another ubisoft game Rainbow six
siege also made this change finally
after a number of lakes which seems like
a phrase I say every day destinies rise
of iron expansion has been officially
announced as we move to the next
an expansion rise of iron will arrive
only on ps4 and xbox one on sep tember
24 30 bucks to play this one you'll need
the base game as well as the dark below
house of wolves and taken king
expansions rise of iron will feature new
areas including the plague lands and
fell winter peak destiny starting area
the wall has also been recreated as a
new area you can visit rise of iron will
include any raid a new strikes more
patrols and public events as well as
more crucible maps and features as you'd
expect there is also a currently
unspecified light level increase and a
new mutated fallen enemy faction among
the new weapons you can get your hands
on are an instance based flaming war
acts as the previously rare gal horn
rocket launcher which you can pick up by
completing a mission in game you can
also get a limited edition version in
black by pre-ordering let me know down
in maximum box what you think of
Destiny's rise of iron expansion and be
sure to stop by against what where we've
got stories on over watches Widowmaker
and dooms and multiplayer that is
everything I've got for you today but do
join me again tomorrow for the top
stories of the entire week I will see
you then